It's hard to believe that 40 years ago,
fleetwood Mac released it's masterpiece
rumors because the record's still sounds
as beautiful and pristine and new as it
did in 1977.
It's a timeless album as far as I'm
concerned,
a work of art that lasts,
and that's really the goal,
isn't it,
for anyone in the creative arts to make
something that feels alive months and
years and decades after it's.
There you go.
So what makes
rumors so good?
Well,
there are of course a lot of reasons.
The skills of the individual band
members,
songwriting craft,
the producers and engineers and the
virtually unlimited budget and time that
fleetwood Mac got from warner brothers
following the release of their self
titled Album,
which was burning up the radio.
That money in time means a lot to a band
like fleetwood Mac who like the Beatles
or Kanye west or frank ocean shines
brightest in the studio where they can
exercise minute control over every part
of a song.
Each track is like a sonic paintings.
As Co producer of rumors can.
Calais wants described it,
and if you're wondering what he means by
that,
just take a listen to the difference
between the demo of Stevie Nicks.
Classic Song Dreams,
which you're hearing right now in the
final product.
This is how it worked with fleetwood
Mac.
In this case,
Stevie Nicks wrote a beautiful piano
melody and lyrics,
and the band in particular,
Lindsey Buckingham,
spent the better part of a year adding
and experimenting to create a rich,
full bodied sonic experience.
At its core,
dreams is a pretty simple song that
consists of only two quarts played over
and over and over again.
Next,
presented the song to the band on a
fender Rhodes piano.
Buckingham added an acoustic guitar and
Christine mcvie played a Hammond b three
organ.
Then Mick fleetwood added drums and John
mcphee added Bass Guitar,
a very hypnotic rhythm section.
The base just alternates between F and g
with some variations,
and the standup part of the drums are
these tapping high hats which run over
everything throughout the whole song.
That's the track fleetwood Mac laid down
at the recording session in Sausalito,
but the song was far from complete.
For example,
Buckingham and the producers were
convinced that the drums were hypnotic
enough,
so they created a loop of eight bar loop
of eight bars,
eight bars,
easier said than done on analog tape
delay.
Also edit a phaser to the high hat so
that they would have a swishy thing,
stick out later,
Buckingham recorded and electric guitar
part,
adding those soupy licks that float
through the verse and then tighten up in
the pre chorus and eventually give way
to an acoustic guitar in the course
itself.
Buildup and release and change across
the sections of a pop song or what make
it compelling to the Listener
Buckingham,
who is a genius at filling in these
kinds of colors and ideas,
usually spur on more ideas.
Calais describes in his book on rumors
that when Nick's heard the new parts of
the song,
she had her own idea for background
vocals and the pre chorus.
She worked out the parts with Christine
mcvie.
They give the sad and dreamlike song and
even more ghostly feel here.
Take a listen.
The song,
of course is about Lindsey Buckingham
and it literally feels like it's
haunting him.
Stevie Nicks wrote it shortly after
their breakup and as she says in the
lyrics,
she couldn't go on because Lindsey
wanted his freedom.
Now in loneliness,
he has to dwell on what he had and what
he lost.
It's a cruel twist of fate that the song
became such a hit that Buckingham had to
spend the next 40 years singing it in
concert.
Anyway,
at this point,
the song was almost done.
Nicks,
Buckingham and big V created a tight
three part vocal harmony for the quarter
and then they brightened up the pre
courses with a vibraphone and the second
chorus with a Conga drum.
Those are both touches that you can
barely hear and certainly don't think
about much when you listen,
but your brain registers the accents.
When Calais mixed the song,
he was careful to put every instrument
in its right place and have a wide range
of sounds from base to midrange treble.
In the case of dreams,
Calais pushed many of the instruments
down to give them a little more base so
that the high hat I talked about earlier
with stand out as well as Nick's
incredible.
Also in the high end is Buckingham's
whining guitar,
a muddled longing response to the sharp
poetry of the lyrics on rumors.
Fleetwood Mac made perfect pop music.
It didn't reinvent the wheel.
It dip the wheel and liquid gold.
These are concise,
gorgeous songs,
stressed up with multicolored sounds,
but built on foundations of real emotion
and real heartbreak.
I think it's pretty safe to say that 40
years from now will still be listening
to fleetwood Mac as John Keats once
wrote.
A thing of beauty is a joy.
Yeah.
Hey everybody.
Thank you so much for watching.
Merry Christmas.
I hope you guys are with people that you
love this holiday season.
I am and I'm excited to celebrate.
This episode was brought to you by
squarespace.
If you want to make a website and you
want it to be a really easy process,
squarespace system,
beautiful award winning designer
templates to choose from that makes the
process so simple.
It's got 24 hour customer service,
no upgrades,
nothing to install,
no patches ever,
and picking your domain name is really
easy.
You can start your free
trial@squarespace.com
and if you use the offer code
nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
Thanks guys.
I'll see you
in 2018.